now let's start to do some more
interesting problems and one of these
things that you'll find in probability
is that you can always do a more
interesting problem so now I'm going to
think about I'm going to take a fair
coin I'm going to flip it flip it three
times and I want to find the probability
of at least one head at least at least
one at least one head out of the three
flips so the easiest way to think about
this is how many equally likely
possibilities there are in the last
video we saw if we flip three if we flip
a coin three times there's eight
possibilities for the first flip there's
two possibilities second flip there's
two possibilities and then the third
flip there are two possibilities so 2
times 2 times 2 there are eight equally
likely possibilities if I'm flipping a
coin three times now how many of those
possibilities have at least one head
well we drew all of the possibilities
over here so we just have to count how
many of these have at least one head so
that's one two three four five six seven
so seven of these have at least one head
in them and this last one does not so
seven of the eight have at least one
head now you're probably thinking okay
Sal you were able to do it by writing
out all of the possibilities but that
would be really hard if I said at least
one head out of you know 20 flips this
worked well because I only had three
flips so let me make it clear this is in
3 flips in in 3 in 3 flips this would
have been a lot harder to do a more
time-consuming to do if I had 20 flips
is there some shortcut here is there's
some other way to think about it and you
couldn't you couldn't just do it in some
simple way you can't just say oh
probability of heads times probability
of heads because if you've got
probability if you've got heads the
first time then you know you don't have
to get heads that anymore or you could
get heads again you don't have to so it
becomes a little bit more a little bit
more complicated but there is an easy
way to think about it where you could
use this methodology right over here
you'll actually see this on a lot of
exams where they make it seem like a
harder problem but if you if you just
think about it in the right way all of a
sudden it becomes simpler one way to
think about it is the probability of at
least one heads in 3 foot
is the same thing this is the same thing
as the probability of not of not getting
not getting all tails all tails right if
we got all tails then we don't have at
least one head so this these two things
are equivalent the probability of
getting at least one head in three flips
is the same thing as the probability of
not getting all tails in three flips let
me write in three in three flips so
what's the probability of not getting
all tails well that's going to be one
minus the probability of getting all
tails the probability of getting all
tails and since it's three flips it's
the probability of tails tails and Tails
because any of the other situations are
going to have at least one head in them
and that's all of the other
possibilities and then this is the only
other leftover possibility if you add
them together you're going to get one
let me let me write it this way the
probability let me write it in a new
color just so you see where this is
coming from the probability of not all
tails not all tails plus the probability
of all tails probability of all tails
well this is essentially exhaustive this
is all of the possible circumstances so
your chances of getting either not all
tails or all tails and these are
mutually exclusive so we can add them so
the probability of let me write it this
way the probability of the probability
of not all tails or just to be clear
what we're doing the probability of not
all tails or the probability or the
probability of all tails all tails is
going to be equal to one these are
mutually exclusive you're either going
to have not all tails you're which means
the head shows up or you're going to
have all tails but you can't have both
of these things happening in system
mutually exclusive and you're saying the
probability of this or this happening
you can add their probabilities and this
takes this is essentially all of the
possible events so all of the
probability of so this is essentially if
you if you combine these this is the
probability of any of the
it's happening and that's going to be a
one or a hundred percent chance so
another way to think about it is the
probability of not all tails is going to
be one minus the probability of all
tails so that's what we did right over
here and the probability of all tails is
pretty straightforward that's the
probability of get it's going to be one
half because you have a one half chance
of getting a tails on the first flip
times let me write it here a little
clearer
so this is going to be one minus the
probability of getting all tails you
will you have a one half chance of
getting tails on the first flip and then
you're going to have to get another
tails on the second flip and then you're
going to have to get another tails on
the third flip and then 1/2 times 1/2
times 1/2 this is going to be this is
going to be 1/8 and then 1 minus 1/8 or
8/8 minus 1/8 is going to be equal to is
going to be equal to 7/8 so we can apply
that to a problem that is harder to do
than writing all of the scenarios like
we did in the first problem we can say
we can say probability the probability
let's say we have 10 flips the
probability of at least 1 head at least
1 head in 10 flips in 10 flips well we
use the same idea this is the same thing
as going this is going to be the product
this is going to be equal to the
probability of not not all tails not all
tails in 10 flips not all tails so we're
just saying the probability of not
getting all of the flips going to be
tail all of the flips is tails not all
tails in 10 flips and this is going to
be this is going to be 1 minus the
probability of flipping tails 10 times
so it's 1 minus 10 tails in a row 10
tails in a row and so this is going to
be equal to this part right over here
let me write this so this is going to be
this one let me just rewrite it this is
equal to 1 minus and this part is going
to be well one tail another tail
those 1/2 times 1/2 I'm going to do this
10 times I'm going to do this 10 times
let me write this a little neater
because I need a 1/2 so that's 5 6 7 8 9
and 10 and so we really just have to the
numerator is going to be 1 so this is
going to be 1 this is going to be equal
to 1 let me do it in that same color of
green this is going to be equal to 1
minus our numerator you just have 1
times itself 10 times so that's 1 and
then on the botton denominator you have
2 times 2 is 4 4 times 2 is 8 16 32 64
128 256 512 1024 over 1024 this is the
same exact same thing as 1 is 1024 over
1024 minus 1 minus 1 over 1024 over 1024
which is equal to 10 23 or 1023 1023
over 1024 we have a common denominator
here so 1,000 doing that same blue over
1000 and 1024 so if you flip a coin 10
times in a row a fair coin your
probability of getting at least one
heads in that 10 flipped it's pretty
high it's 1,000 23 over 1,024 you can
get a calculator out to figure that out
in terms of a percentage actually let me
just do that just for fun so if we have
1,000 23 divided by 1024 that gives us
you have a 99.9% chance that you're
going to have at least at least one
heads so this is if we round this is
equal to 99.9% chance and I rounded a
little bit it's actually slightly even
slightly higher than that and this is a
pretty powerful tool or a pretty
powerful way to think about it because
it would have taken you forever to write
all of the scenarios down in fact there
would have been 1020
four scenarios to write down so this
would have this this doing this exercise
for 10 flips would have would have would
have taken up all of our time but when
you think about in a slightly different
way when you just say look the
probability of getting at least one
heads in 10 flips is the same thing as
the probability of not getting all tails
and that's 1 minus the probability of
getting all tails and this is actually a
pretty easy thing to think about